Mình sẽ tâm dự bảo khi tâm thuy văn của ra hồi người bà dơ ngày 30 tháng tâm.
Vì chỉ tâm át thâm dựa ở vọc khoảng 18,000 đổ bi vắc.
Một trong 18,000 đông trên vùng viện khi đông của bật bóc biến đông.
Sức gió mạnh nhất, vùng gần tâm át thấp dựa, mạnh tấp sấu,
tức là từ 18,000 đẹp bụng chính, kyll mến mũ rật tâm.
Át thấp dựa dưới chuyển theo hướng tay, với tóc lộ khoảng 20,000 đổ.
Dự bảo trong 20,000 đổ dưới.
Át thấp dựa dưới chuyển theo hướng tay bóc.
Tức giữa bảo trong 40,000 đổ tựa, át thấp dựa dưới chuyển theo hướng tay,
tây bóc. Tóc lộ khoảng 20,000 đổ bi vắc.
Bùng viện ở vọc khoảng 20,000 đổ bi vắc.
Tư kích tuyến một trong 18,000 đổ biến đông.
Cấp lộ dưới rau thiên tay, tóc bà đối với vùng viện,
phía vắc khu vực bóc biến đông.
Về tóc đồng của át tham dựa dưới, vùng viện phía vắc,
khu vực bóc biến đông, có rõ mạnh tức sấu.
Dật tâm, sống biển cao từ 20,000 đông.
Tổ thuyên hạt động trong các vùng viện nổi trên,
điều của khả năng chữ tất cả đổ của giống lộ gió mạnh và sống lớn.